okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at biological sequences
and the implementation of language
heading for the upcoming version 12.2
all right so um
let's start off with this overview so
we've looked at some of the stuff
and i have you been
i'm i'm trying to remember what where we
had been uh
where we have been at we
i think john has implemented many if not
all of the suggestions from the last
time
we met with some of the emerald folks
for some of the
secondary structures and john has some
initial
implementations of the function
overloading the string processing that
you had to address it
i think that's a excellent okay that's a
good summary
i think that's right yes okay so let's
just let's just look through these
functions to begin with
okay so we've got biosequence
biosequenceq i hate these q functions
but i guess we have to have it
okay so if i put a um if i put an
n in there it will happily
what is it doing okay what the heck
what was this about i think that's a uh
something just with the prototype build
but that should be the last time that
you see it
okay fine all right okay anyway so this
was a sequence
and and somewhere in it it has an n and
if i now say so now
let's say i want to make proteins out of
this how do i do that
uh say biosequence translate
what's the difference between convert
and translate
uh if you if you have say translate you
have more options about what translation
tables you can use
and also you don't have to type the word
peptide
okay so if i just say this this is the
default
eukaryotic whatever they are creature
that's right but i i mean we already
know it's eukaryote from the fact that
has ts in it right
okay now what just happened there so now
it's given uh
a sort of all of the translations to the
peptide sequences
available from the sequence above
expanding out oh i see it expanded
by default it expanded the n into all
the possibilities
that's right okay so if i were to put
another speak
what's that that's what we said last
week should happen
okay so if i put another n there why do
i only get four
why would i get 16 let's see here so
that happens to be at the uh the third
base
and the third base is often degenerate
they often will
many codons will map the same sequence
so by chance
you've gotten ones that happen to map to
the same
okay i'm convinced okay
um so wait a minute so these are
different
that dot means what does that dot mean
uh dots are typically decoded for the
stop character
okay all right so what can i do with
these these things now
can i now that i've got these peptide
sequences what can i now do
let's see here you can open each of them
up you can get things like
molecular weights you could do uh
alignment with them there's a there's a
there's
some kind of okay how do i get the
molecular weight of all of these
what's the function to get the molecular
weight a slot of
molecular weight mapped over
nope no what's this how do i get the
molecular weight
it should be molecule mass i'm sorry i
was muted sorry
and why is it called molecule mass
rather than molecular weight oh that's
uh
i know that's a long history about this
as i know we had ancestors discussions
in the united framework about this
what is this what what is the right term
mate
god we still don't have that bug fixed
with with the selection
and the prototype build does anybody
know what's happened to that okay what
the heck is that plus
dot that's
all we don't know debate of the start
codon
yeah that should just be truncated
that's a bug
okay always good that i can find these
in less than a minute
i'm not sure i managed to do it in this
case the
um
um okay so now
random instance of that biosequence okay
string match q
circular dna of this beautiful okay so
now
now uh you're saying string reverse just
works
on these that's right
and you're sure this is what we want
because i'm sure this will give some
internal discussion
i think so we definitely don't want a
biosequence string
um
what which ones are we supporting i mean
if i do string
um string repeat will that work not yet
uh the goal is just to work my way
through
kind of all of them on the string the
string page this is what just happens to
be implemented
as of this meeting i mean there are many
of them
not that many i mean string pad left
i don't know plural eyes we hardly need
we don't need that one
things like edit distance are we
supporting that natively
yeah we we do have those kinds of things
right
we have string alignment when we have
the various string distances i'll make
sure that edit distance also works
okay so has it has it been discussed
whether these functions which
also operate on lists of strings
would work on lists of biosequences
because that cannot be done with up
values
i would not go there honestly because i
think even the current behavior on this
is inconsistent
i think that's a future issue i i take
your point
and it's probably probably in a perfect
world it would work correctly for that
but let's not worry about that right now
right just bring it up that's something
that the colonel folk often
bring up and arguing against uh value
type things
okay okay so we've got
okay so what is this these are
translation tables okay biosequence
types amino acids circular dna
et cetera let's see last time we ran
into a bunch of biology questions which
we couldn't answer what were those
questions can you remind me
i think there were there was a question
about let's see here
the question is about gluing things
together gluing sequences together
yes that's the major one yeah okay so
explain that question
so there is a compound bios
biosequence and kind of the question is
kind of what's the standard
and what was the standard interpretation
of that what does it mean compound do we
have that right now a compound
so yeah if you go if you go to the
detailed section
and then uh new functions
biosequence
and then scroll down a bit
steve our live stream is suggesting that
iconography
should look like the mr dna from
original jurassic park
i don't know what is it what did that
look like
was it cool the look
um
uh images
oh boy well amusing but i don't think it
quite makes it
but highly amusing there could replace
it with the wolf
yeah right there um
okay in any case the the compound
biosequence
still further down a bit
let's see here
yeah we're still we're still in the
various forms of single ones keep going
here we go sort of towards the end there
okay hold on biosequence of bracket one
i'm a little bit confused by this how do
i get if i say
let me pick a different gene because i
want to pick a slightly
oh who knows a simple gene let's see i
think i think
hemoglobin gene isn't that fairly simple
and i think there's some you can ignore
those error messages those
that are prototype stuff okay all right
so
i've got this thing now and now let's
say i want to take this
and i want to know uh well let's just do
this thing molecular mass just so i'm
just trying to understand
what i'm what i'm getting here so this
this would be
okay um and now if i take this
and i say string a percent
10 then
okay that's cool
by the way do we want in these summaries
do we want to give
the beginning and end blah blah dot dot
dot
end like two thirds at the beginning one
third at the end anybody got a biology
opinion about that
no
i don't think that it would be much
different from
this i don't think that it matters
because
especially for long sequences uh it
doesn't really matter whether you can
see the beginning
and middle whatever but it is no but
wait a minute what i'm asking is
aren't the two ends more important than
what's in the middle for lots of kinds
of purposes
or am i confused it could be for
specific types of dna but i wouldn't say
that's a general
truth okay
um brad what does emerald do about this
yeah we would show the beginning in the
end just for that exact reason you have
there when when i reverse it or reverse
complement it it's nice to just see that
it matches up with what i expect
that's a good point for the visual
confirmation yeah
all right let's do two thirds one third
two thirds of the characters at the
dot dot dot one third for the end do you
get what i'm saying
john you understand what i'm saying i
understand yes
okay um
and i don't quite understand why you're
not listing sequence i mean to me
it's an above the fold story what the
sequence length is here
and it will be good to indicate that it
seems to me above the fold
yeah that's a good that's a great idea
and that'll particularly help with the
zero length sequences yeah right which
otherwise will be utterly obscure
it would be in grey over the daughter
many
yes i agree although i think you
probably want to
don't want to count the first 10
yourself yeah right exactly
i would just put paren and gray how many
there are
length you know
length column whatever it is
um okay but let's
let's look where did you have these
these mixed
things up you already went too far
well oh here this thing here
okay okay what is none i don't
understand any of this
none is a convenience for when uh
that kind of we don't have a standard
alphabet that applies and you just would
like to put something in quickly
okay the suggestion from
steve on the live stream is actually a
little bit more content for which is
which is could could we use some color
to indicate something interesting
about the sequence uh in the icon here
that's an interesting idea so make the
make the excuse
symbol or the the icon dependent on the
concrete sequence
that's right which we do in many many
other places of course we haven't done
it here
if we can think of something interesting
to do with it i think that would be
terrific
also we typically don't do it if it gets
too big like a 500 meg interpolating
function we do not
indeed we just punt to something generic
okay but let's go back down here
okay so what is this creature
this is a peptide sort of with a dna but
what i mean you get those two things in
actual chemistry
and you put them in a in a you know in a
test tube and they just hang out
together right then what do they do
it's a chemistry question people
probably can most comment because
my understanding is they deal with this
situation a lot
can you can you say what what you know
a peptide meets dna what happens
somebody chemistry person or
i don't know about peptides so much um
ribosomes obviously are peptides and
they do
interact with uh rna to to make
more proteins uh but what i'm comes to
mind
for me is micro rnas um
binding with uh single-stranded dna
to uh turn it off for example sure or
or other transfer that's a that's a
binding so that's not look
what they're in a test tube that's what
you asked for yeah i understand that i
write
so what you're answering is exactly what
i was afraid of
right which is this makes it seem like
you've got one sequence followed by
another sequence followed by another
sequence
but you're talking about binding which
is not that
that's right i think jordan has a future
section for how to deal with this mr
brandt okay but what does this mean
does somebody know what this means
because i think this is meaningless
unless proved otherwise i think this is
meaningless you know this is not an
object that exists in the physical world
is it no it's it's i feel like it's the
same like a molecule you have a molecule
with three
not yet bound together objects
okay so this is hydrogen hydrogen or
with some
activity glue okay so
do the emerald folk have a comment on
this anybody
in our syntax this would mean that the
three pieces are conjugated together in
some way
we don't currently have a way to specify
that that's something we talked about in
the future so
it would be kind of implicit if there's
dna next to rna
there's you know physically there is
something in the middle that makes the
interaction happen but
they are physically bound together in
the way that we represent it like that
would that be a linear sequence or would
they
would be some kind of binding one strand
to the other
it would be linear okay end to end yeah
the binding between strands with the
extra hydrogen bonds and stuff is done
through our secondary structure
specification through the the bonds
okay which okay
but but i feel like to be consistent
with our decisions over these unknown
molecules
we must assume they are not yet bound
together
right so this is a biosequence this is
just
a a cluster of biosequence molecules
basically that have
unknown binding characteristics a first
statement
these are fl free floating in a test
tube with
with i mean but this means and again i
mean i'm being perhaps very naive but
stoichiometrically this means that the
same amount of this this and this
is that true i
don't think we make any statement about
the mountains here
like with small like again the power
lady molecule
if you have a molecule with two elements
inside we don't claim one of them is
more frequent than the other no but if
you have nacl
and you've got just the the na and the
cl there
it's not na2cl7 of course
right even though you might not
represent that as
standard binding right it's it's still
just
stoichiometrically it's the it's this
it's some known ratio of those things
well for molecule it's exactly one to
one for the nacl example
it's not in na2cl2 the way we understand
that i don't like this interpretation
honestly
okay all right because i feel like we we
consider single things on the
microscopic level we don't make any
statements about microscopic
concentrations
yeah but i don't think you can say i
mean it's like i have a list of numbers
3 7 12. i've only got 1 3 1
7 and 1 12 there i'm not saying there's
any number of
of you know the the um okay
this is the case i mean i don't know any
case where we where we would think of a
list of things
and imagine that they're you know it's
some kind of generalized
set where you're saying that it's these
things in any concentrations
seems wrong to me no i don't think so
i'm arguing exactly the opposite
because it's not microscopic the meaning
of concentration makes no sense at this
level
oh i see what you're saying okay so
you're saying
i've got this
well but but look okay you're right that
i mean if i'm making an nacl crystal
and i don't know where the edges of the
crystal are saying it's an equal amount
of n a and c l doesn't really make any
sense if the crystal is small enough
you know the boundary is going to be a
significant part of the story
is that kind of what you're saying no
like our molecule is literally just one
single molecule
we could argue if in a radiation field
or not but but there's nobody else
around
you understand but some things okay look
let's take
let's take you say xenon and uh
you know neon okay one atom of xenon one
atom of neon
okay what is it what is the thing that
you have if we say molecule
of xenon neon what does it mean
in infinite vacuum under the condition
of some background field that stabilizes
the sink there's
somewhere one atom of this and somewhere
one atom of this
okay what would we say if we said we
have a mole
of you know helium xenon
that's the expert ex sedan question and
we had long discussions about this
and we have a well from alpha version of
this but we don't have yet
a boyfriend language version of this
okay but so
but the answer is that that in that case
it's going to matter
right whether there's equal numbers
equal absolutely
okay i think this is a mess
right and i think that that you're
basically going to be
you know thrown into the question of are
these bound are they not bound
if then you know if they're bound do
they are they end to end are they
somehow you know binding to some
you know other part of the thing i think
this is a big mess and i and i think
this question about relative amounts
is also a big mess and i don't how
important is it
i mean if we how important is it to
support this
who cares about supporting this why is
this important
i think go ahead michael i think we
heard heard from travel as well as from
emerald that this is a very common
situation
can somebody from emerald comment on
that
so we definitely need the way to stick
things together you know you you
mentioned
um you're talking about amounts we have
sort of a separate way to deal with that
we have the notion of a state where you
specify amounts of
individual things but uh even without
the amounts we want to be able to look
at a
you know a set of things and ask what
possible reactions like what is the
reactivity of this
this collection of things together and
the actual amounts you end up with
depends on the
concentrations i understand but this is
completely not that
this is a biosequence right to say that
there's a collection of chemicals and
then you do things with them like you
ask about reactions between them
that's a fine thing but that's just a
list of chemicals and you're asking
about
questions about reactions this here says
it's a biosequence that consists of a
bunch of biosequences
now i i did here you know i think trevor
in his lab does things with this and
maybe there's specific
um i mean this is not the story of
maybe let's take it simplest example uh
we want definitely to represent
a double-stranded dna so we need
at least two strands of dna that we put
in
one biosequence and then add hydrogen
hydrogen
bonds yes but but look in this case
you've got
end to end if this means anything it
means i mean
there are three things this could mean
okay thing number one
random molecules floating around in a
test tube
together okay thing number two
end-to-end connections you know two
stranded pieces of dna you know glued
together
end to end thing number three
two double single stranded dna
things that are actually zipped together
i strongly advocate number one
because the only consistent
interpretation this molecule
okay okay but now
okay then how do i get from number one
to number three how do i say zip them
together uh john did you not have a
section further down
i think you're muted oh yeah that's all
the way down
in the in the considerations for after
12.2
so
where should i look here well that's
lovely that's here
that's lovely yeah great
so so i mean we can just generate these
right given an rna we can we can
generate this picture
a decent speed is that a true statement
not yet
okay and and how
i mean if we use you know like
i don't know somebody's like muhammad's
you know
protein structure technology
is it worth us trying to put some
protein structure computation and
i would say yes but let's first
clear out the basics okay
somebody we should talk to muhammad
about that
he would have a lot of good opinions
about the representation
well he has actual technology for you
know that seems to be sort of
leading the world at this point indeed
so
we should talk to him about that but
here you see how two
rnas are clued together
where do i see that in here in the exam
the first one in the examples
oh my god and the generic point we can
discuss
what kind of hydrogen points we need
so this this thing
okay this is
this is surely not the right way to do
this i mean in other words
this is a generalized bond in some sense
right a bond connects two atoms
this is connecting two i mean an atom is
a point
in the euclidean sense no no no i think
you misunderstood
this is this is the c from number one
with the a or this the g from number two
it's it's not a quadruple point between
four things
it's index notation
my gosh it's and it's referring to the
bases not to
atoms within the molecule no no i
understand that i understand that but
but what happens if it zipped if the
whole thing is zippered
up and most of the dna is
double-stranded it's got little pieces
where it's
you know where at the end you know it's
got this giant piece of dna
and it's mostly zippered together but
the zipper
is open at one end does that i mean that
obviously happens biologically but i
don't know whether
does it it doesn't stay in that state it
just unzips or it zips up
is that right
do you understand the scenario i'm
talking about
yes but i do not know if it's german
dynamically stable or not
i thought it needed you know it needed a
um
some enzyme-like thing
can somebody comment right i would guess
once there is a hydrogen bond it should
be reasonably stable
well once the dna is formed but i'm
asking the question look i'm trying to
understand
what is the structure what types of
molecules hang out there
are there things where it is mostly
double stranded but the double strand
has come apart and it's single standard
for a while is that
is that a thing that happens or is that
not something we have to worry about for
some reason
can somebody comment on that does
anybody know that that does happen with
topo isomerase that opens up the double
strands
so that one of the strands can be uh
transcribed
to rna okay
so so this representation will be a
total mess in that case
we could do a span or something in case
that point sometimes the syntax supports
it but that's something we're going to
need
yeah probably multiple spam
there's a bit of an example above that
where there's the text the protein
feature example right above there
there's kind of an example of a
potential sequence notation
what is this no protein
uh right yeah right above there
right where right at the end of kind of
the rna examples
it may be convenient to have a span form
to capture a large number of lengths
and then there's you say that it's a
it's a bond sequence of some kind
instead of just particular discrete
bonds
does that does that have the right
precedence
that whole puppy oh it does wow we
okay cool so okay so that means that
span no that's not consistent with what
you just
were feeding me okay well anyway
this is for the future but there were
additional list brackets because here we
have only one strand which is self
bonded
oh gosh
okay all right so so basically
and what you don't have the capability
to do is to annotate
in in sequence so to speak
this is externally and that's the first
that
yeah that's that's the first example
there
is uh giving some uh
some excellent coding sequences this
thing here
no the one the one above that the very
first first one
is doing some annotation no but i i know
but the point that i'm making is it is
externally annotated that is
the string is the raw string then you're
saying there's annotation to the string
it's not i'm just commenting on the
design of the thing right it's it's
probably correct
spicy but again it's it's pretty similar
to molecule we don't
serialize the molecule and have the
bonds at the bond at the bond we have
first atoms and then the bonds
or measures we first have the
coordinates and then the
primitives formed out of them yeah okay
fair enough okay so this is the sequence
and then this is
the um
i mean i don't understand why we've got
lowercase exons and
things like this um
uh that was derived from an existing
standard but that will change
okay okay but but so what is this well
okay
should we be looking at this let's let's
concentrate on the 12 1 stuff
what else should we do yeah what's that
okay what are the questions what are the
outstanding questions here
what's one major change from the last
time was we got rid
of the whole number of functions we got
rid of
counting functions and inverse things
and we've really consolidated them
i know i can see that and that's good
okay so let's let's understand here
let's go back up to the top
okay so transcribe
means this is two rna
generically is that right right
okay and translate is two peptides
generically
is that right that's right
and and we can translate either from rna
or from dna to peptides is that right
that's right
okay what are the things that
biosequence modify can do
biosequence modify can currently jump to
start codons
it can uh trim what does it mean
what does it mean jump to what does it
mean jump to does it mean drop things
first
that's right okay fine
okay what does flat and common
subsequences do
so if you have a compound sequence and
then there's a dna and another dna
it will combine them together
look this compound thing is a mess right
that's doing yet a different thing
what's that doing is that aligning from
the beginning
to decide how to compound them together
did you understand my question if you
say flatten common sequences
is it the case that you line up the two
dnas
no no no they're still in sequence but
they become now one
unnecessary one right
i see so you're imagining that they form
a sequence so you've got a bunch of
fragments
exactly okay now i'm beginning to buy
this a little bit more so so
the case that seems to make sense to me
is you've got a bunch of dna fragments
that you got from some algorithm
and then you've got a biosequence of a
bunch of dna fragments
and then you simply say i want to put
these all together
and i don't quite know why string join
doesn't do that
would probably be done
yeah questions but we don't necessarily
have
bio sequence on the outside i mean if
you have string join
look if you have a string join whose
arguments are a bunch of biosequences it
should presumably join the sequences
if you have a string join that is a list
of biosequences unfortunately that's
implementationally difficult
but conceptually that should work and
as a hack basically for right now
if you say string join of biosequence of
the list
that should just work does that make
sense
yep that's perfect if they're all dna
i understand i understand if they're not
we have no freaking idea what to do
we should get an error message unless
somebody can tell me the chemistry of
what should happen
i think you train you only do it for
equal ones yeah and
circular dna good luck what are you
gonna do
i mean it's amusing but but i don't see
what you do
um
okay um
well this all looks cool let's see we
have
the folks from emerald should comment on
whether whether
i mean if there's anything that they
would like to see here
they should make sure it's known
because this is our opportunity
um
okay well i look forward to being able
to actually run this in your lab
and uh type in i'm sure there's some
function that you guys have
um where i can just give it some
sequence here and i can say go make me a
vial of this and
mail it to me yes we do
um not looking forward to translating
our own system to this though but
so for i think from what we've seen last
time and now uh
it supports pretty much all the stuff we
can do now at least
good but hopefully it won't be too hard
i i
i is your chance to push your things on
us then you have less work to do
that's true
um
okay
well let's see what else should we do in
this review
um
sequence type sequence string
what is chemical pattern list what is oh
pattern list
okay if i say chemical list let me try
that
will i get the obvious thing then
um don't forget to get don't don't
forget to
get autocompletes set up for this
biosequence case
all right well the obvious this would be
the list of chemicals right
if there is a list of chemicals i don't
know what it does in the case
go ahead yeah that's kind of the
question what should i do then
well maybe it should give an error
message that makes sense
i mean i don't think we want to give the
wrong i mean i mean a lot of the time it
will be very definite right
so so this should certainly work
right yeah that makes sense
okay this
why is it called molecular mass here but
molecular weight in other places in the
system
i thought we had mostly faced
outerweight don't we okay all right fine
so if i say something like um caffeine
i don't know what that means
relative molecular mass well at least it
says molecular mass
there have been a lot of discussion in
the last 10
20 years in various international bodies
that this weight was never a good idea
to use
correct because it doesn't have units
well i
think that's what makes it so wonderful
wait a minute wait
wait wait wait wait this relative
molecular mass is the unit free
thing whereas molecular mass has atomic
mass units is that correct you ask for
more
weight you usually mean the uh the the
the unitless version
is the correct which is what you're now
calling relative molecular mass
that is the that is that the property
name yeah
okay so so but which is what everybody
else would call molecular weight
correct okay did it's phased out
yeah well phased by who i mean like
applied in pure chemistry yeah i
understand
i mean i'm always suspicious no no
i was gonna make various very silly
comments about these international
bodies that ratify different kinds of
things and
and what that really happens inside
those those objects but
right i mean at the end of the day usage
dictates
meaning exactly um what is this thing
is it a is it an interval what is that
yeah that's right it has
imprecise terms in it so it calculates i
i understand that point i'm
i'm trying to understand what it
actually is
so if i say percent 16 divided by 7 for
example
it'll just work great
okay you know that font is very weird
and i think we could probably do
something better than that at least we
can get
and this is a detailed thing for a
different group of people
um okay
is it not the same point as the rest it
is i know it is but it has one okay
do you want another one i think so okay
i can't discuss with jose
yeah i mean i think so it's not obvious
to me but it seems like so
because you know because look the point
is that's not code
and it kind of looks like code you see
what i'm saying
it's like it's like something which i
see what you mean
the it confuses me i'm thinking i see
what you mean
yeah um okay
so i feel like so we are not quite sure
yet from what usa so are you fine with
the nested one or do you don't want any
nested one right now
no i'm i'm now okay with the nested one
given that
if you're nesting identical objects you
know identical
sequence molecules then i think i know
what it means it's
end-to-end connection
what do you mean by nested one but did
this is what i
didn't think it would be oh listen
but you guys just told me that we can do
a string join on it and then it joins
end to end
yes but this doesn't mean before the
string joined the audio joint well but
it means that
were you two you were to think of them
as lining themselves up like that rather
than free floating in the test tube
where they could be in a different order
but they question whether
whether we want to allow um whether we
have a need for disconnected biosequence
uh
structures right so like you can have a
molecule that is just
it's like a graph and it follows the
rules of graph it can have
you can have a disconnected uh jumble of
atoms because it's
it's just a microscopic model they say
like
the the precise molecular mass would be
different because of binding energy
oh my god what kind of worms
so i just mean i mean so with a molecule
you can have a disconnected structure
and it's and it's useful
and you're going to tell me this would
just would it be useful for a
biosequencer because if we
if we do assume it is bound then we need
some more
information what exactly is the clue oh
absolutely because what you're telling
me and i hadn't even
internalized this point is those little
clusters of atoms
depending on how far apart they are the
aggregated thing will have different
molecular weight because of different
binding energy
right you pull these ionic thingies
apart
they will have you know less binding
energy
yep i mean i mean it's usually lower
than the uh
the um the the precision with which you
measure them
yeah but even in principle what a can of
worms because we're going to end up with
the same thing with nuclei one day well
this is
some four times seven minus 10
approximately
what is did the relative change for many
things
a couple of times 10 to the minus 10.
explain that number i mean because
that's like a meter compared to the size
of the atom
no that's kind of amc squared kind of
the
the typical binding issues
i see is there's electron volt type
energy
which is today at the edge of what can
be measured so it's no longer
fiction right
okay okay okay i mean one
other thing that we did discuss that we
didn't write down this
we could maybe have a very special head
like glue off and then you put your glue
inside like a certain
exotic molecule but but but but
but where is it i mean in other words
it's either gluing those
those sequences together end to end
or it's floating glue along with other
stuff
right but kind of this clue would mean
it's not floating because
it's not a biosequence okay let me let
me show my complete lack of knowledge of
biology
when when you talk about things like
phosphorylation and things like that
how do these things were that's a
modification to the sequence isn't it
what happens it's other molecules
binding to the to pieces of the dna or
something
i'm i'm very naive here can somebody
help me out
phosphorylation on proteins is adding
phosphate groups
to things like searing uh residues that
have a hydroxyl
uh so you're modifying one of the one or
more of the residues
okay so how do we represent when we have
a protein sequence
and we have some phosphorylation of that
protein sequence
how do we represent that in biosequence
yeah that's with the below proposal
where we then say
you know along these particular terms
there's this particular
link which uh corresponds to this
particular modification
but what you're saying is that is that's
this
annotation is that right that's how you
would indicate things like
that that's right
yeah because they don't have a large
enough alphabet to
cover phosphorylation methylation far
insulation or all other kinds of
post-translational modifications that
can occur
okay another showing my utter ignorance
but these
rna eye things what are these these
little
what don't aren't what are they do they
relate to this
what are they do you know what i'm
talking about
like in transfer rna
well rnai is interfering rnas
yes how do those work that isn't that
isn't that isn't that some binding of
one
they they bind i think with messenger
rna and interfere with its translation
it's
uh yeah translation to protein
right but don't they don't they bind
onto the messenger rna
i mean aren't they like uh maybe i'm
confused about how i believe that's what
happens
so it's kind of like a generalization of
things like this phosphorylation
modification
uh yes and it would happen the actual
binding would be over a number of of
bases yes
i know that was the that was so so what
i'm hearing from you
is this post-translation modification
is a that is a modified biosequence
that has had you know things
you know attached you know on well
in the case of in the case of the rna i
don't think it's post-translation it's
it's some you know it's actually
pre-translation
right yes it would be it would be and
the other things would be covalent
methylation
of dna residues uh or phosphorylation as
you had said on on protein residues
those are all covalent uh binding events
and we would have to annotate you know
where it occurs in the given sequence
uh because the alphabet doesn't have
special letters for that
okay but so so just so i understand in
in
again biology naivete right
this phosphorylation stuff it happens
it's like snipping
type it's it looks like single nuclear i
mean it's it's a single
single peptide things it's not like over
a range of
of you know over that's right yeah it's
individual
uh residues that would be phosphorylated
you know
just you know typically only one um
some some enzymes uh you can
uh you know like um uh
it's map k you can phosphorylate it up
to three times i forget
uh what the map stands for okay
is there a notation for a phosphorylated
protein
is there any standard notation like in
the sort of the standard kind of
stringy bioinformatics world
john i defer to you on that i don't
believe so actually i think that's
that they they resort to annotations as
well
okay what other kinds of annotations are
there i mean there are obviously
annotations that represent the meaning
of some sequence right like like how do
you say
or do you say do you carry along hello
this is the binding site
on this protein does that get carried in
the data structure
yeah then we have one right here come on
the second line the tf
kind of binding site i see
how big is that you know when you're
talking about these types how big is
that
i see so there's a gene there
oh boy i do not like this
strand plus oh boy
okay so this is so there's a there's a
kind of a calculus of annotations here
which i mean so for example let's say
that you had type gene
stand plus blah blah then you say
um complement you you take biosequence
complement
what does it do does it change that
annotation what does it do
i think in a case of a reverse
that's one of the few cases where you
can preserve
a lot a lot of these things you know you
know you've you've kind of gone over to
uh maybe kind of like the negative
strand of course
the i mean but these sites then are no
longer meaningful because you're no long
what's on the the compliment strand is
no longer coding for this
this eden gene so i think most of the
operations would end up
uh a couple yeah a couple would throw it
away
in the case of something like where we
say
uh translate that's that's kind of
the advantage of this notation
is that then we pass translate this
kind of this biosequence modify splice
by feature
and we can use the coding regions to
actually
you know splice out okay one or the
other proteins that actually come let's
go in so
you're saying that in in the translate
you would actually be using these
annotations to decide how to do the
translation
yeah we could yeah that's great
well so in in principle with translate
then you probably need to give two cases
right
well what is it you know either well
okay how do you drop the annotations
let's say i have a biosequence i just
don't want the annotations what do i do
i mean presumably there's an accessor
for biosequence that drops the
annotations
right right i mean this this that's
going to be a killer
for people you know they well and maybe
not i mean maybe they want to carry the
stuff along
it would be just one of the modified
strings
yeah i see so you'd have to do that
all right but otherwise so i don't see
it quite as annotation i see it more
like
uh in molecule the bonds
i see it's not some random
habit some of
maybe we should separate them
potentially
you mean things that have structural
content versus
i mean so so you know this is an exon
what is cds what is cdf that's the code
the coding regions so so these are the
things that actually once you
kind of finally get down to the base
level these are the regions that are
grabbed to make the protein
and what's the difference between the
what the
introns is that
i thought again biology naivete
right i thought there were introns and
exons and that
uh what's the difference
okay biology moment can somebody explain
this to me
how does this work when you have i
thought you had
coding i i thought the exons were the
coding region the introns were the
non-coding region
am i completely wrong how does this work
somebody help me out here i do not know
i i think it's it's yet there's kind of
yet another step these are the
what kind of will leave in terms of
you know that kind of there being you
know messenger rna so
that's the stuff that'll actually get
out there and you know and travel to the
ribosome
but what actually ends up getting
finally
you know finally processed ends up being
these coding sequences
which are subsequences there so so gene
splicing structure here
that's right is i mean this is a rather
simple gene that i've picked here okay
and entron there which is snipped out
right
the exon which is a coding region is it
not
it it also includes things like the
uh the initiating sequence
to the ribosome so yeah i get it okay
okay so
so you're saying cds is a subset of the
exons
that is the actual transcribed sequence
without stop codons and all kinds of
other junk like that
yeah okay so so this is in fact an over
counting so there's an incompatibility i
mean if i
said i have an exon and it's here and
the cds was not within the axon i'd be
i'd i'd have to be lying is that correct
i believe that's right yeah that's right
okay
and is it deterministic given the exon
is it deterministic what the coding
region is
or is that still i mean because clearly
you know
now even given you know
in this case there's kind of the same
mrna transfer both the protein 3 and
protein 4
so the there are cases where even
even there there's still room for
variation
by the way i'm curious sandra on the
live stream is mentioning this
the sept1 gene disaster
and excel and i am just curious whether
that just sort of missed by a few months
uh uh you know the um
uh the work that's now getting announced
with with um
with us and microsoft and excel um
it's kind of a sad thing if that just
missed by a few months being perfect
of not having to have that issue
interesting
uh um
michael probably knows but he might not
yes
working on it okay okay
the um
okay well so so what else do we need to
discuss about this i mean so this
i find this strand plus thing absolutely
horrifying
if we're going to say this which should
be plus not a quotes plus sign i think
i mean we might have some shortened
notation yeah
yeah um but but anyway this was
post 12 2 which just want to make sure
that we have structurally away forward
for
for more complicated things that we want
to add to the things that we want to
add for 12. right but so what you're
saying is
i'm just utterly confused by this i mean
this mrna
is saying how to peel off no i'm i'm
just
monumentally confused here i mean i
thought
but you see this is this is one feature
of biology that
that you know when i learned it you know
50 years ago in school or something
the the um you know there were all these
you know organelles of unknown function
and stuff like that
and now you know
like there were red blood cells and
white blood cells right
and now there are you know cd8 positive
you know
t cell something or others it seems like
it's it's a self-similar thing that
every time you think you know how
biology works
it's got some other level of complexity
so i don't know what
i just have no idea what the difference
between the mrna the exon the cds and so
on are
um and do they really occur together but
i think maybe we don't have the right
group to answer that here
um maybe when we review the ontology
of these for when that this entity main
point is
the main point here is that what you're
expressing here is both
pure annotation like if we have a graph
and we're labeling
you know this edge is going to be
labeled
labeled labeled labeled with you know uh
you know i don't know um
you know um you know predator
of or something like this right
it's just a label the actual structure
of the graph says you're joining
um you know fox
to hair or something right um
but and that's what's in the graph but
then there's a label that says something
and there's a quite different thing well
i mean this is so complicated
because there most of our graph
operations are
label independent so to speak they just
do what they do to the graph
and then our calculus of annotations
theory is basically saying which
annotations get carried along when what
happens
now making sense like when we do a graph
union we can carry along some
annotations but not others
so so the question is here
you're saying and i'm again i'm i'm
confusing myself but i mean in a graph
we have things like weights of edges
weights of vertices and so on
and some operations take account of
those and others do not
and i suppose that's the analogy to what
you're doing here with you know
this piece is part of the coding
sequence and some operations care about
that and others do not
yes that's right
uh ah dan our live stream is saying
exons can be non-coding from a
pre-or mrna before splicing
or the post-splicing rna
does not have an open reading frame cds
typically spans multiple exons
okay thank you i i i understand that
this is this is in the yeah
okay all right so i mean these all have
slightly different meanings as the basic
point
but but what what we're saying design
wise
is it's like a graph where what we do
right now is to have
annotations that represent things like
vertex weights but there is a base level
of the graph
that you can just you know manipulate as
a graph without knowing about those
weights
and i suppose here we're doing
essentially exactly the same thing
i'm just michael do you do you
agree with that analysis i mean that
this is similar i think so
yeah and what's the analogy in the
chemistry system
to this i mean in other words if i
wanted to annotate a molecule
saying you know this part of the
molecule is very important or this part
of the molecule has some special
feature is that do we have a way to
annotate inside molecule
that's uh active area under discussion
in the chemistry
coop okay stereochemistry business the
stereochemistry would fall into that
category where
it might be destroyed depending on the
modification you make
i see um what else but i mean just
general
like uh this is my special carbon or
something we have
the user would just keep track of that
separately
right although although maybe we should
allow them to do that i mean by the time
you know the stereochemistry has direct
consequences for things like
you know rendering of the molecule and
things but what other annotations are
there
i mean i have to believe again i'm i'm
i'm stretching my knowledge of chemistry
but aren't there these
these weird what are they i'm see this
is so embarrassing i know this subject
so poorly i mean these
resonant bond thingies and things these
weird kinds of bonds that happen and so
on
that are not captured by your standard
bond representation am i right and i
come talking
that would be delocalized bonds perhaps
if you
um yeah that's one thing right the
closest we have is are the aromatic
that has which is very specific right so
the aromatic bonds are a very specific
type of delocalized bond
but in general is it not correct that in
the quantum chemistry of these things
that you know you could you could have
stuff like that happening is that true
or is that not some
or is is it locked down enough i mean in
other words
at some level you're describing a very
mushy system because you're describing
this complicated quantum mechanical
system
that you're trying to describe in this
sort of
simplified symbolic form and i guess i'm
asking
are there other things beyond
stereochemistry
that have some structural consequence
that are
you know an attempt to describe better
this quantum mechanical
mush right i mean the different levels
because i mean at the end of the day
i mean they're at the bottom of the
level like or with quant with quantum
mechanics it is all just a big
uh bag of uh nuclei with with the
electrons that follow whatever wave
function
uh they have um and we we put various
levels of uh of structure on that to
help us understand it right so we and
we've got these covalent bonds
uh and we're talking in the group about
uh
putting different types of bonds than
the traditional ones like
hydrogen bonds or just so what on earth
are we doing with hydrogen bonds
uh nothing at the moment okay which
uh if you give us a structure that
that has a hydrogen
acceptor near a hydrogen
then possibly it would show up in our in
the force field
uh um energy that you compute but maybe
perhaps not um yeah but i mean
representing an actual hydrogen bonded
thing i mean you don't usually see
i mean don't they usually have these
things with little dotted lines and so
on representing
maybe i don't know what i'm talking
about but they typically do with a
dotted line like that but we don't
have a structural representation in
molecule right
now for that we're talking about it
along with other types
of of coordination uh for example
between
um metal atoms and uh
other atoms that have electron pairs
like oxygens and nitrogens
that could coordinate with it
uh but we're just talking at this point
right
but if i'm going to be really difficult
here right imagine water for example
right which we know has little clusters
of molecules and liquid phase forming
you know you know at what point
do we give up so in other words it is
not the case that water is really h2o
it's really got some little you know
clusters of i don't know you know with
some probability it's got some cluster
of 10 molecules or something
this goes back to discussion we had in
the very beginning
what do we mean by molecule and i still
stand more or less this is one separated
in an infinite universe this is not
a bike material
and we're definitely interested in
making a data structure to represent
crystals
um but and we think that in the i mean
that
it should be separate than the molecule
by the way this person
uh claudio is just working on some
function repository stuff for crystals i
assume you've seen that
like an acl it can be under
with a lot of trouble you can make the
single free floating and a cl molecule
right sorry just confirm claudio who is
working with
yes uh bob you worked uh yes claudia was
one of my students this summer
yeah yeah we're definitely looking at
that as
fun i mean he's going to put a bunch of
stuff in the function repository as a
as a kind of get a starting point for
the crystallography stuff
um i mean it is not the end point but it
is a starting point and it will allow
people
to do you know basic visualization of
crystal structures and so on in a nice
clean way
yeah absolutely so
i mean so so annotating atoms within a
molecule right uh um one way that
has traditionally been done in uh uh in
software throughout
throughout the ages i guess uh for the
past few decades right
is uh isotope tagging them right you you
just uh
um and it's kind of a hack but it works
across different software structures
right when you want to
you want to watch that carbon uh through
a process
no you said it's carbon 13 or something
right right
uh that's horrifying it's portable
across different software how do you
represent
the smiles have a way to represent
isotopes yeah
how do you do it so uh so you use a hard
bracket
and you put the number the integer
before the atomic symbol
so you survive beyond belief
you see this these are the kinds of
hacks that eventually blow up in
everybody's face
you know that that's how you end up with
spacecraft for the wrong you know
with with the you know with the fuel
measured in the wrong units and so on
the let's try to avoid that
the um no but but okay so what you're
saying is
there is
but by the way we have do we have we
have isotopes right we can deal with
an atom that is a different isotope yes
absolutely
um and um
but but okay so one of the questions is
when you annotate a molecule there is
sort of
point annotation of but it you know for
stereochemistry obviously you're
annotating a group of atoms
to to say you know what is its you know
left-handedness right-handers whatever
else so i guess my question would be
in general you are annotating on the
same things coming up for these
biosequences you're annotating
uh some kind of subset of the of the
objects that are in the structure some
sequence of peptides some collection of
nearby atoms etc
usually i suspect you're annotating
nearby things in the structure although
that might not always be the case
because you might have some folding
thingy where too you know there's some
weird hydrogen bond that goes across two
things that are
in you know that appear to be in
different places in the structure
is is that correct guys
they have some proteins all the time
right but but so right but i mean so my
question is
what we're going to need in the end is
annotations
that are essentially a subset of the
underlying objects
i mean this this feels very much like
what we're doing in meshes for example
where we have these underlying things
and then we're putting
a a sort of superstructure on top of
that that says
you've got these underlying points
you've got these underlying polygons
whatever else
now this is how you are coordinating
them together
for purposes of this annotation and
those go
in the in your mesh uh uh after the list
of coordinates right so you've got
that's correct your list of coordinate
your illicit points
and then um relationships among those
points and those are
defined relationships with their own
head right uh
the polygon line those types of those
elements um i think there are other
relationships that you can give too
but but yes right and
and so so having those those undefined
heads uh
i that's how i view the stereo right i
mean it's a
relationship between a group of atoms um
but i mean we've got the ability to go
further with with just plain
annotation rules right so if we um if we
want
we can apply um so i don't know how
related this is but i mean you could
imagine
uh have put all that stuff into the an
annotation rules option as in the graph
the annotation rules that we're using
for graphs and meshes and so on
right and i am definitely i am uh
putting those uh trying to integrate
that those with molecules okay so what
you're saying is a different plan
right is to use the annotation
structures of graph
i mean one plan is what we do with
meshes where it's like you have
the objects and then you give their
relationships
okay another plan is it's like graph or
you have
well in in graph you have the same thing
actually the first argument is the
is the node's second argument is the
edges um
but and and then you have annotations in
addition to that
right right and in the graph structure
if you wanted to put some type of
i keep thinking of them as hyper edges i
mean this relationship between multiple
vertices more than two vertices
there would be no place in the graph
structure and you could imagine
shoehorning them in to the annotation
rules
well are you telling me that what you
need is is hypographs
because we're going to have more
hypergraph stuff i mean we've got you
know for the physics project we've got
really pretty good you know we've got a
lot of high-powered stuff for dealing
with directed hypergraphs
which is actually exactly what you want
for stereochemistry i think
otherwise hypergraph often people think
of hypergraphs as undirected hypergraphs
where you just have
buckets of of nodes um you know
associated together at a hyperedge but
in the physics project we have directed
hyperedges
which is i think what you need for
stereochemistry am i right am i wrong
i think so it's a it's a an ordered set
of
of atoms that's what we can change
you change
and so for us i mean i would i would
give it a head like stereo group or
something i mean so we've got
tetra we've got multiple types of uh
stereo uh
that i would want to to describe in this
um and i
really hope that i'm not uh derailing
the biosequence meeting with
talking about the stereos no i think
that i think it's relevant because i
mean basically what we've got
look what we're trying to check here is
that we're not cutting ourselves off for
the design
um and we're trying to check that there
are there are basically
two models for annotation one is
annotation rules
the other is the mesh-like way of doing
it
okay i tend to think that
oh boy i mean there's arguments for both
of them because
and and maybe we have both of them and
maybe we have certain things
in that are as complicated
so with my first use case for annotation
rules and molecule is
i mean uh you want you want to specify
what the tool tip
on an atom or a bond is you want to
specify the all the the other wrappers
that can be be applied in an input form
they get put why can't you just write
tooltip when
when you put um around an atom in
um well so that that's the that's the
way that a user would enter it but then
in canonicalizing it it's put into the
annotation rules
fine i see
but if you want a tooltip a cluster of
atoms
can you do that or not like in a bio
sequence
you know you might want to tool tip some
region
in the sequence
by the way when do we get viewers for
the i mean like like the picture that's
on the right
in wolfman alpha when will we get
something like this
in um in in the language
because this thing here is basically i
presumably
i could have a sequence here and you
know like these exons and things like
that
that this is exactly what i'm you know i
i should be able to display these kinds
of things and that's what all of these
you know last 15 years or something or
maybe it's more than that i'm losing
track of time
these um uh these various hierarchical
gene viewer
type things provide
yeah that's right that'll come right
along with the representation
okay okay fine
we still work on the representation so
when we have that out we can do that
right question from our live stream
about do we have mass spectrometry
and infrared spectroscopy data we
actually have a project there was a
project
there's a project underway for um
molecular spectroscopy stuff by an
outside person maybe bob remembers that
i'm not sure what and in terms of mass
spectrometry
isn't that just computing you know
counts of numbers of atoms and things
or am i confused no so i mean it it
uh remember so it seems like you really
ought to be able to make the
compute the the mass spec from a given
molecule or whatnot dutch but uh
one is the fragmentation of the molecule
and then for a given molecular ion
based on the natural abundance of the
different isotopes
the you know the peak for that is
actually a multiplet
of certain intensities and those
intensities are very easily computed
with certain assumptions about you know
the natural abundance so
yeah like which mine did you mine that
tantalum from well yeah
i mean even down to that uh in fact
that's how they
uh determine the uh origin
of different samples right
right and andy and for dating as well
um oxygen 18 16 ratios and so on
oh famously carbon 14. and carbon well
yeah well that's trace i don't you think
you'll pick that up with mass spec
i see let's see they mentioned infrared
uh at the moment we're
limited to uh i mean uh importing data
from uh
computational so you compute the the
spectrum and you
you import the the the frequency
although you guys are
when are you going to have electron
electronic structure stuff
you're working on that weren't you right
uh i mean so i i had found a library
that allowed computing it uh and
and wrote something it'd take a lot of
time
more and more of the electronic
structure packages are starting to
have libraries that you can plug into
them so that they can be part of a
bigger
uh time as in
as in to compute electronic structure
for any given molecule you'll be
spending 10 hours of cpu time or what
no i just mean i mean we need a
developer to to spend
uh i mean so i've i've written a lot of
tools for
uh to automate the process of writing
these library link packets uh
um and if i had somebody to work on that
yeah okay
should ask sushma i think she's got some
relevant people now
you should make that you should ask her
i'm making a note
um okay anything else we should make
sure to cover in this meeting
okay in terms of the core 12.2
functionality
we're largely good to go i think so i
think great
i mean okay then we will concentrate on
the documentation and
implementing more of the string
functions sounds good looking great
i mean i look forward to seeing this i'm
gonna i need to run it on my own genome
i need to presumably i can with this
i mean you know a standard workflow
right i've got all the you know i can
pull up my mitochondrion or something
that would be a simple piece
um and then i would just turn that into
a biosequence
so presumably i should take my genome
is that going to work it's an encore
it's i mean i can read in the
chromosomes pretty easily
right and and then what i should then
get
i mean i've got a faster file so i would
just say
by the way will will the faster import
have a biosequence
um element so i can import the faster
file into a biosequence
that's on the list but otherwise i just
say biosequence of
dna comma import faster file right
or yeah you you might have to grab out
just the sequence
part of the fastball no no no what what
we do
um uh in um
um uh uh the um
um um
i wasn't gonna say actually you know
this is amusing
i actually have got my whole sequence
done twice now at about a 10-year
interval
but quite quite coincidentally um
and i i've been meaning to compare the
two um
and i wonder what i'm going to find
i don't think i i i don't expect
retroviruses to have attacked me in the
intervening period i suspect more like
the uh you know changes in sequencing
technology
um but uh uh but anyway so
so no what you get from faster import is
just a straight
uh you know dna sequence i mean that
that's the default element
for faster import um now i don't know
which
i mean there's some often some strand
confusion right so if i just say
biosequence of dna comma
and then some sequence which what is the
strandiness what what what is assumed
there
do you understand my question which is
by default there's there's no strand
assumed it's indeterminate
what do you mean i mean i see so but if
i take my mitochondrion
right and i just import it i've got you
know i got the faster file
um the um uh
um
um and right and then you want to map it
against the
the reference and there's a function
that's not going to make this release
called locate a sequence where it
figures out where it is on the genome
and a science the strand and the
positions and all that good stuff but
but we have already genome lookup right
right so you can do that too yeah i mean
if i if i just type in
some random um
you know if i type in and we've had this
for like
more than a decade now if i just type in
some random
sequence here the defaults will be so
that by the way presumably can be
replaced by biosequences is that true
should be replaced by biosequences
no you have no chromosome at the moment
because this is not a sequence this is
the precision on some higher structure
yes but we're going to need that
yes but probably i would say more so
entity related things
really
there is not kind of an auburn
chromosome one and the most natural
view and entity that has certain oh yeah
sure for sure for sure that's right
but this structure this data structure
if i say
go turn that thing into actual an actual
sequence there
oh yeah yeah yeah so so the these could
give back
embedded biosequences which then you say
give just give me the sequence that
it's well right i mean and and you know
for example we know what build number
that chromosome was
and that obviously that would be the
entity information
exactly
but you're saying i mean you know in
general i would want to take some
sequence
and i would want to annotate it in some
way because i want to know what
i mean you know like i take by
you know my mitochondrion and i want to
find you know haplo
groups or whatever whatever it is
um and um uh
how would i what's the workflow for
doing that here
so i've got my mitochondria and
it's a biosequence somehow the faster
file
presumably okay presumably and the level
of the faster file it knows whether it's
a plus c
plus strand or not
correct
and right now we are getting rid of that
necessarily
okay okay fine but but if it does
we should preserve that when we get the
biosequence out because right now
what we're doing is you know if i just
take a random faster file
i'm um um you know if i were just to
pull in my genome which is stored as
faster files i literally drag it into
this notebook it will
come out as the default element the
default element is
the um
uh you know is that sequence unknown
whether it's the plus strand or not
presumably as the plus strand
um but if we had biosequence then
perhaps that default should change
to being the full biosequence which says
what strand it is and so on
right and the faster file presumably
says that it's dna
not whatever else and then
what is concerning me slightly is the
obvious thing i'm going to want to do
is compare that sequence to the
reference sequence and find snips
and things so what is our imagined
workflow for that because
finding snips is very similar to what i
just did up there with genome lookup
which is i want to say you know it's
in the end a disembodied snip is a
relative
to this you know uh reference bio
sequence
what is the what am i a reference
relative to a reference bio sequence so
to speak
they're making sense i mean this is an
example yeah the generalized snip what
we have here on the screen
um how do we imagine we're going to do
this
yeah so there's a function that's not
going to make it
called locate biosequence alignments
which
takes kind of the the biosequence that's
given in
and finds an alignment with the
reference sequence
and from there you can also we can also
specify
once we have the alignment we can say
okay what what snips
occur along this alignment we have i get
it but what we don't have is a
representation
of you know rs blah blah blah snip
right that
you know that is something which is
relative to the reference sequence
yeah that you get back kind of
the list of you know of structures that
say
here's what the snip is here's where it
is on the biosequence you provided
here's where it is on the reference
sequence
here's what the flanking sequences are
yeah
yeah yeah something like that i mean
but but i i i think there's a missing
structure here which is
the thing we're seeing on the screen
which is a
i mean something we don't have in many
other places which is you've got a
string
and now you're saying it's characters
seven through eleven of the string
right you know we don't usually have a
structure that means that we don't need
that structure
you either take out those characters or
you just have the
the um um the
yeah there's there's a there's a post
12.2 structure which is unfortunately
broken right now called embedded
biosequence
for this purpose where you say we have
some larger reference feature
or some larger entity and we're just
talking about where the coordinates are
and from it you can get back okay what
what what's what sequence are you
referring to what's its flanking
sequences
uh what strand is it on and all this
kind of good stuff
right okay
um
okay sounds good um okay anything else
we need to cover
nope all right well thanks thanks
everybody
thanks everyone thanks thanks thanks
stephen thanks
yup and thanks